with almost 500 sessions at next 2018
it's understandable that you couldn't
get to them all so if you didn't see my
talk from zero to ml and Google cloud
platform then stay tuned because here's
the route wind maybe you've never built
a machine learning model before or maybe
you're a hardcore ml expert no matter
your level of experience we've got
something for you on Google cloud in
this talk I covered our spectrum of
machine learning offerings from products
targeted towards application developers
with little or no machine learning
experience to tools for folks with more
ml expertise the talk covered three of
our cloud machine learning products
machine learning api's auto ml and ML
engine let's get a quick taste of each
section starting with machine learning
api's our ml API is make it easy to add
machine learning to your app with a
single REST API request no ml expertise
or training data required we've got five
api's to help you with common ml tasks
analyzing images analyzing video
converting audio to text analyzing text
and translating text into over a hundred
languages I highlighted our vision and
natural language API is with live demos
showing how you can try these api's
directly in the browser then we had a
cameo from Nick hasty director of R&D at
giffy an app for searching and sharing
millions of gifts Nick shared how giffy
is using the vision and natural language
AP is to optimize giffy search and gift
tagging Nick showed us that the ML ap
eyes are a great way to get up and
running with ml quickly but what if you
need to customize them with your own
data that's where our newest addition to
cloud machine learning comes in cloud
auto ml announced in beta a next Auto ml
lets you train vision natural language
and translation models with your own
data no model code required in the auto
ml section I showed live demos of each
variants in the auto ml UI starting with
vision I demoed a model that can detect
the type of cloud in an image well you
could use the vision API to tell you an
image has a cloud we wouldn't expect it
to identify the scientific name of a
cloud this model can classify five
different types of clouds Auto ml
natural language lets you build custom
text classification models train
on your own text data I showed a demo
using a data set from the nonprofit
DonorsChoose which matches teachers who
need resources for their classroom with
interested donors with Auto ml NL I
built a model to categorize need request
from teachers into categories so that
donors can easily be matched with
projects they're interested in auto ml
translate lets you build domain-specific
translation models for translating
industry specific jargon and linguistic
nuances there are many instances where
the Cloud translation API will work just
fine but certain cases require a
translation model trained on your own
custom data for example let's say I see
the following error message on my
machine I can summarize it as the driver
is not working but what if I need to
translate this summary in our case we
know this refers to software but taken
out of context the translation is
ambiguous it could be referring to a
broken golf club
the driver club isn't working the same
sentence could also refer to a taxi
driver who is on strike and therefore
not working a base model wouldn't know
which domain is referred to and this is
where a custom model comes in handy
I showed a live demo of Auto ml
translate using data provided by our
customer we localized I'm incredibly
excited about Auto ml because it makes
custom models accessible to anyone
regardless of their ML expertise but
there are cases where you have a custom
task and need more control over the type
of model you're using and the inputs to
that model that brings us to the third
section of the talk cloud ml engine ml
engine is a managed platform for
training and serving your own custom ml
models it supports models built with
tensorflow Karos scikit-learn and XG
boost you can leverage ml engines GPUs
and TP use to train models and you can
deploy your models to ml engine for
serving to show ML engine my teammates a
Coquille came on stage to share a live
demo Zak and I each built models
independently to accomplish the same
task I built one in tensorflow and he
built one using scikit-learn we used ml
engine to serve them and Zack showed how
easy it is to build a front-end that
cause different versions of your model
even if they were built with entirely
different frameworks and dependencies
well that's it the top covered a lot of
material and I hope it gave you an idea
of the variety of ML offerings we have
on Google cloud if you'd like to see the
full talk check out the link in the
description
below and don't forget to subscribe to
the cloud YouTube channel for more great
next rewind content thanks for watching
[Music]